[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue seule chaîne
parlementaire bonjour catllar besoins
mutuels et on va refaire en somme cette
dernière semaine de campagne
présidentielle oui une émission
essentiellement consacré donc au scrutin
de dimanche avec notre invité olivier
rouquan bourgeot z politologue auteur de
en finir avec le président c'est le
titre paru aux éditions françois bourin
on revoit avec vous les thèmes qui ont
fait la campagne cette semaine
évidemment dans cette dernière semaine
d'entre deux tours il y avait un moment
phare le débat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous ça a été un vrai combat se débat
face à face sa marque évidemment cette
dernière semaine d'entre deux tours
résumé de cette semaine françois chevret
le duel emmanuel macron marine le pen
elle peut être le plus virulent de la
vème république
avec un point culminant le débat de
mercredi soir
votre stratégie c'est simplement de dire
beaucoup de mensonges et de dire tout ce
qui ne va pas dans le pays mais vous ne
proposez rien vous êtes à plat ventre en
permanence devant le syndicat la nature
devant lui au fief devant les
communautaristes suis dedans les
puissances d'argent entre différents les
banques à plat ventre imed les
hostilités commencent dix jours plus tôt
le soir du premier tour
emmanuel macron arrivé en tête est
désormais grand favori se présente
triomphant devant ses supporters je
souhaite dans quinze jours devenir votre
président le président des patriotes
face à la menace des nationalistes trois
jours plus tard pour lancer sa campagne
d'entre deux tours emmanuel macron
choisi amiens il rencontre les syndicats
de l'usiné world poule menacée de
fermeture
mais au même moment surprise marine le
pen et sur le parking de lusine
accueilli très chaleureusement par les
salariés je suis ici à ma place
exactement là où je dois être au milieu
des salariés de leur poule
au milieu de ses salariés
juste à cette mondialisation sauvage à
ce modèle économique est honteux un coup
d'éclat qui oblige emmanuel macron à se
rendre lui aussi parmi les ouvriers
accueille un peu plus hostile l'arthrite
cul sic je me battrai pour qu'elle se
fasse
mercredi soir marine le pen a dénoncé un
emmanuel macron loin du peuple
héritier du dernier quinquennat une
stratégie offensive pour tenter de
rattraper son retard dans les sondages
alors on va commencer par ce débat parce
que c'est quand même l'élément le plus
important de cette semaine politique et
de campagne présidentielle qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensez vous de ce débat
certains disent que c'est le pire de la
vème république bien disons que c'est un
débat dans les codes de communication
son nouveau renouveler parce que
finalement on a une la communication des
réseaux sociaux qui est une
communication instantanée rapide assez
agressive qui finalement s'est imposé à
la télévision pour ce débat du second
tour qui est une quasi institution mais
là on a vu cette quasi institution
finalement complètement implosé j'allais
lire on explose les codes ont explosé
les journalistes d'ailleurs qui
symbolisent les arbitres étaient là
ennuyée il serait plus comment faire
respecter le ne serait ce que le temps
est donc cette c'était une série tweet
oro j'allais presque dire assez
agressive pendant plusieurs heures
donc un renouvellement du code de la
communication violence agressivité c'est
aussi les mots qu'il ressentait dans la
presse étrangère qui a vu se débat comme
un débat non pas la française butin
l'américaine est ce que c'est aussi
votre analyse alors à l'américaine oui
il est vrai qu'on a on a un peu souvent
la femme fatale comparaison qui vient à
l'esprit assez facilement c'est vrai des
attaques frontales
bon il faut le rappeler surtout dû à la
stratégie de marine le pen qui était
pleinement dans son rôle de deux d'attac
d'entrée attaque très vives
emmanuel macron lui plutôt dans le rôle
du dos rond mais qui a résisté qui a
contre-attaqué dont il est vrai que
l'analogie avec les états unis peut peut
marcher mais disons que si on peut dire
que c'est une évolution mondiale ses
seins de 7 ce rythme et de ce style des
réseaux sociaux qui s'impose maintenant
à la communication politique et ça je
crois que c'est une évolution assez
structurelles et substantielles on peut
peut-être revenir la stratégie de la
star seront va ré écouter des éléments
mais simplement peut-être est-ce qu'il
permet de faire bouger les lignes
ce débat sans vote à oui c'est rarement
10 ans un constat qui est fait des
champs les autres débats duels on a
rarement dit même si on mémorise certain
moment qu'on dit sur cet échange intel
gagne il gagne le coût symbolique mais
on a rarement ndiqué ensuite à on va
dire un échange musclé que les
déplacements de vote significatif été
fait cette fois ci on peut s'interroger
on peut s'interroger dans tous les cas
donc pas sur qui va gagner et qui va
perdre mais sur des déplacements
on voit dans les intentions de vote que
ça bouge un peu et que cette ode à l'it
et agressive dans tous les cas aura pu
dérouter un certain nombre d'électeurs
notamment les plus âgés qui apprécie peu
la d'accord à regarder cet exemple
justement des chances dès le début
finalement du débat monsieur macro et de
candidats de la mondialisation sauvage
de l'ubs et risation de la précarité de
la brutalité sociale de la guerre de
tous contre tous du communautarisme et
tout cela piloté par monsieur hollande à
moi je vais pas vous dire que vous êtes
la véritable héritière du parti
politique de l'extrême droite française
la question qui est posée aujourd'hui à
nos concitoyens c'est de savoir s'ils
veulent l'esprit de défaites que vous
portez face à cet esprit de défaite
moi je porte l'esprit de conquête
français voilà alors vous le verrez le
dire un instant que ce ton agressif a pu
influencer certains électeurs est ce que
cette stratégie d' attaque à outrance de
marine le pen ne s'est pas retourné
contre elle prend les commentaires ont
été globalement négatif donc de ce point
de vue
et le bruit qui est fait après le média
compte toujours après le débat compte
toujours comme de soin de nous on peut
dire que c'est globalement négative par
contre pour bien arrimer un électorat en
colère incarner cette colère et le faire
de façon assez assez net assez brutale
assez familière
le temps était parfois très familier de
ce point de vue ça peut marcher il c'est
à dire que au moins on peut dire qu'elle
aura sans doute consolider un électorat
remonté contre le sont solides et ça
veut pas dire qu elle ait cherché
d'autres électeurs et peut-être espérer
gagner passé les 50 % de ce point de vue
c'est un échec et c'était donc plus une
stratégie on va dire
deux opposants pour le futur de premier
opposant pour le futur qu'une stratégie
de victoire qui a été décalé à l'acte la
défaite est la stratégie lactée lac télé
le rapport de force que lui donner les
sondages n'a pas cherché à augmenter
de ce point de vue les intentions de
vote et les électeurs parce que sans
quoi il fallait s'installer dans le
fauteuil du presque président et roule
c'est bien malgré tout dans dans l'image
de la fonction il y à une nécessaire
retenue nécessaire sérénité nécessaire
courtoisie républicaine la marine le pen
s'était inscrite totalement en faux par
rapport à ceux enregistrés nous dit donc
que dimanche
soit il ya peu de chances que marine le
pen keynes et 50 cent pourra gagner oui
on peut on peut se risquer aujourd'hui à
faire ce constat
sauf véritable j'allais dire phénomène
de dernier moment mais qu'il peut pour
l'instant qui n'est pas identique a bien
parlé tout à l'heure des états unis et
ça s'est passé avec donald trump face à
hillary clinton ça ne peut pas se
produire en france aujourd'hui
ben e comparaison n'est pas raison c'est
à dire qu'on sait bien qu aux etats unis
le mode de scrutin n'est pas le même
finalement on fait sans arrêt la
comparaison les états unis mais ce sont
les grands électeurs qui votent et si on
regarde de l'élection américaine il ne
faut pas oublier qu'en termes de
suffrages
c'est bien hillary clinton qui les a
découverts majoré presse l'élection
était fait c'est ça les analyses étaient
l'élection des fêtes et la réalité ce
n'était pas du tout celle ci donc oui
bon alors il ne faut pas en effet il ne
faut pas annoncer le résultat avant le
vote s'est toujours c'est toujours mal
perçue d'ailleurs par l'électorat à
juste titre mais au jour d'aujourd'hui
au vu des informations dont nous
disposons il semblerait conditionnait
qu' on est conditionnelle à tout à fait
vrai vote aura bien lieu dimanche en
attendant les deux candidats ont mis
leurs dernières forces dans la campagne
emmanuel macron était en meeting à albi
et marine le pen à hénin dans la somme
extraits de ses meetings j'ai été la
voix du peuple de france qui n'en peut
plus qui n'en peut plus et qu'il ya eu
une chance une chance dimanche de dire
qu' il est le seul souverain dans notre
pays
je sais qu'il y en a et peut-être parmi
vous qui ont premier tour ont suivi ou
françois fillon ou benoît hamon ou jean
luc mélenchon ou d'autres candidats et
je les respecte le jeu démocratique
la règle de notre démocratie c'est de
choisir entre les candidats de deuxième
tour et donc de prendre ses
responsabilités on parle souvent de
réservoir de voix est ce que emmanuel
macron et marine le pen respectivement
des réserves de voix et lesquels seront
d'abord il ya la stratégie qui permet
d'aller chercher de nouveaux électeurs
c'est ça le réservoir de voix ou d'un on
vient dire que pour marine le pen pour
l'instant sa stratégie n'était pas de
cet ordre
pour emmanuel macron les réservoirs de
voix le potentiel électoral il est où
bon il est évidemment dans ces électeurs
fillonniste qui dans un certain nombre
disent qu'ils pourraient aller voter
pour emmanuel macron donc lui par
rapport à ceux ci il ne faut pas les
choquer il ne faut pas les heurter il ne
faut pas les peurs il faut les séduire
et de ce point de vue on peut dire que
dans le débat qui a été celui donc du
second tour
il a été très prudent il a rappelé un
certain nombre de propositions très
pro-européenne très même économiquement
relativement libérale donc il va bien
d'autres portes ça qu'il est resté en
disant mon programme
il est à prendre ou à laisser quelque
part oui mais il a pris quand même il a
pris une certaine assurance sur le thème
qui est important pour eux à savoir la
sécurité la lutte contre le terrorisme
il s'est positionné en chef d'état y
dédient - chefs d'état - chef des armées
il a fait de nouvelles propositions en
termes de sécurité avec notamment sur le
terrain de la proximité deux
propositions qu'on attendait pas donc il
à lui essayé d'ouvrir du côté de cet
électorat qui te rassurer un électorat
assez âgées bon moi qui va plutôt à
droite l'électorat fillon du premier
tout fait ça à l'électorat de françois
fillon du premier tour ou au delà des
lectorats bon assez bon par contre il
n'a pas elle n'a pas ouvert sur le
social il a très peu ouvert sur l'eau
sociale et de soin du sahara en
l'opération il est clair que c'est
difficile tant il ya ici ambivalence il
n'a pas ouvert vers l'électorat de jean
luc mélenchon avec des propositions
propositions sociales par exemple tout à
l'heure dans l'élément sonore convient
d'écouter il dit c'est un peu la règle
démocratique
au deuxième tour on va voter forcément
pour celui qui est en position d'aller
voter
est-ce que ça quand on est de gauche de
droite ou quand on est français qui se
sont abstenus
sa sentence à est ce que les gens
acceptent cette prise de parole de
d'emmanuel macron c'est un peu raide
pour des réalités
oui c'est ça c'est un peu ce n'est pas
très séduisante à aller voter et presque
par obligation vous êtes obligés d'aller
voter pour moi si ce en quoi bon c'est
un peu là encore le registre qu'il a
voulu utiliser dans ton sec
il est aujourd'hui moins opérationnelle
qui à dos reis 15 ans c'est à dire le
front républicain mobilise moi
aujourd'hui notamment l'électorat jeune
qui qui est arrivé à maturité politique
alors que le front national changé son
discours est sûre d'incarnation donc
pour lui l'idée dire c'est un parti
d'extrême droite qui met en danger la
république il faut leur expliquer alors
ça surgissent de l'obligation
sera moins ses effectifs et moins
mobilisateur on le voit dans les
enquêtes d'opinion les les indécis les
abstentionnistes cce la clé du scrutin
on le dit mais ce sera ce sera vraiment
le cas oui jour important on peut pas
vraiment les mesures et donc si il est
vrai en plus jusqu'au dernier jour le
nombre d'indécis voir le nombre
d'abstentionnistes peu évolué alors ils
sont évalués aujourd'hui entre 24 25 %
pour les abstentionnistes
une quinzaine pour les indécis ça fait
du monde en effet une question quand
même quel que soit le président qui sera
élu par défaut
oui alors tout dépend de ce qu'on entend
par défaut et c'est l'ambiguïté là où ça
vous entendu ce mot cette semaine louis
et c'est l'ambiguïté des enquêtes
d'opinion c'est hier par défaut par
défaut quel d'accord voilà mais par
défaut de l'un par défaut de quoi on
peut à mon avis se risquer à dire si
vous voulez que le président élu est un
président j'allais presque dire lit dans
un contexte chaotique c'est dire les
repères les repères notamment
idéologiques sont moins saillants don
qui sera élu par défaut j'allais dire
d'identité on perçoit le projet on
perçoit l'incarnation
mais ça manque de prise donc oui par
défaut de repères olivier ou quand vous
parliez tout à l'heure de jean luc
mélenchon en tout cas des électeurs jean
luc mélenchon c'est aussi une question
de cette fin de campagne que faut-il
faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au lendemain de sa défaite jean luc
mélenchon avait appelé ses adhérents
ducasse exprimé par un vote par une
forme de référendum qui a été soumis que
doivent-ils faire ils se sont exprimés
et voici le résultat
résumé par astrid de vilaine les
militants de la france insoumise se
divisent en trois catégories 36 % sont
favorables à un vote blanc ou nul
dimanche prochain 34 % d'entre eux
voteront pour emmanuel macron et 29 %
font le choix de l'abstention
si l'on additionne les bulletins blancs
nuls
ainsi que l'abstention les insoumis sont
donc 65% à ne pas se prononcer pour le
front républicain
oui parce que le front républicain n'a
pas de sens en l'espèce donc sont pas
des gens qui donnent crédit en fait à 7
ce concept à cette notion là le fameux
front républicain de 2002 on a bien vu
que c'était une formule qui finalement
n'avait pas réussi à faire baisser le
front national au contraire un résultat
vivement critiqué par les partis
traditionnels
écoutez moi je réagis avec
incompréhension
la gauche traditionnellement a toujours
été dans ce combat et françois savane
l'a rappelé contre le front national
on est au deuxième tour d'une
présidentielle
il ya un choix qui s'impose celui qui
consiste à défendre les valeurs de la
république dont je rappelle la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité monsieur
mélenchon et dans une ambiguïté total
ces électeurs s'apprêtent soit
s'abstenir soit voter blanc soit voter
marine le pen et ça en très large
majorité
ça veut dire que les extrêmes convergent
pour fracasser la république face à ces
extrêmes
il faut faire barrage jean luc mélenchon
ne dévoilera pas pour qui ils votent
dimanche prochain mais il a mis en garde
ses électeurs contre ceux qu'il nomme la
terrible erreur de voter pour le front
national
je viens ou quand est ce que jean luc
mélenchon a créé les conditions de
l'ambiguïté oui oui il a une
responsabilité majeure parce qu'il a en
plus suscité au dernier moment un espoir
une véritable attractivité sa campagne
démarrée il double son score dans les
dernières semaines
donc il y à là si vous voulez un
charisme qui s'est installée en charisme
fort sa campagne a été commentée sur un
mode très positifs et tout de suite
après le premier tour cette position de
retrait par rapport au jeu alors on peut
penser que c'est un calcul stratégique
pour préparer l'avenir mais c'est très
très risqué par social et législatif
c'est ce que voulait dire législatives
et puis la suite de la structuration
d'un mouvement sur la gauche du ps dont
on sent bien que comme il est en
position de force il veut attirer une
plaie à une partie du ps vers lui et des
électeurs la gauche
les frondeurs ceci étant dit on peut là
tout à fait s'interroger sur le choix de
ce cette position en retrait par rapport
quand même la question de se joindre ou
que vous payez
oui alors s'il est vrai que c'est très
ambivalents comme l'électorat parce
qu'une partie va se dire l'électorat le
plus en colère où l'électorat qui n'a
pas en tête les repères d'un front
national danger pour la république bon
ça va moins de choquer mais toute une
partie de l'électorat très ancré à
gauche sur la mémoire du combat contre
le fascisme pour les années 30 et puis
ensuite que contre l'extrême droite dans
la longue durée
ça ne peut que le heurter malgré tout
donc c'était une position très difficile
pour lui et un choix qui est qui est
assez ambivalent et dont il est
difficile de mesurer les résultats
notamment sur les législatives
il ya actuellement un groupe communiste
on sait que les discussions pour les
laisser ça se passe très mal
enfin tout cas ça se passe pas forcément
bien avec l'été les communistes assez
mal avant qu'est ce que ça va donner
comme on peut se demander si la
recomposition de la gauche avec un parti
on va dire de la gauche radicale ou
assouvi on peut reprendre ce terme est
soumise assez fort ou un mouvement dans
tous les cas on peut se demander si
c'est pas en train de partir avec
habiter le lot tada du fait de la
réaction du parti communiste et la vraie
barbe et c'est une période très
intéressante où il ya beaucoup de
manières d'interrogation beaucoup
d'inconnues on est complètement dans la
recomposition du paysage politique
français selon vous je crois qu'on est
engagé dans une période de recomposition
et alors ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que les législatives vont être
d'actes marqueur de ce 6e tour de
l'élection présidentielle si vous
l'appelez comme cela oui oui je pense
que tout à fait c'est les législatives
vont être vraiment prise au sérieux
donc je ne sais pas si troisième tour de
l'élection présidentielle s'ils sont les
législatives mais les tableaux se dire
actuellement si emmanuel macron aura ou
pas une majorité certains parlent de
évoque un scénario de cohabitation
d'hôtes de coalition temps du crâne à
gauche voilà exact il a une majorité
avec son mouvement en marche ce sera
l'inconnue parce que ce mouvement est
tout neuf sera-t-il suffisamment solides
pour tenir cinq ans une majorité
voiliers modernes
c'est un mouvement qui est en train de
se transformer en parti politique la vie
de la vie politique française est
traditionnellement organisée autour de
deux parties alors il est en train s'il
a des candidats ce qui semble être le
cas sur l'ensemble du territoire
si il est capable de mener de campagne
législative homogène on pourra dire que
à l'instar de ski à configurer le
gaullisme au début de la vème république
toute comparaison et raison garder mais
on aura peut-être la transformation en
parti politique
alors on va poursuivre sur cette
thématique puisque l'actualité cette
semaine c'est aussi la droite qui
prépare le terrain des législatives
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya eu un bureau politique cette
semaine chez les élèves et c'est
françois baroin qui a été choisi pour
mener la campagne dlr pour les
législatives résumé de stéphanie des
pierres les républicains ont désigné
leur champion c'est françois baroin qui
mènera la bataille des législatives
son nom a fait l'unanimité au bureau
politique mardi soir il a d'emblée mis
en garde ceux qui s'écarterait de la
ligne officielle du parti qui appelle à
faire barrage au fn
tout ce qui se rapproche le pen avance
contre exclu tout ce qui se rapproche du
front national pour législatives après
j'ajoute que tous ceux qui se
rapprocheront de macron avant
législatives seront exactement dans la
même tarif pour épauler françois baroin
pendant la campagne une équipe d'une
quarantaine de ténor censé refléter
toutes les tendances du parti et de son
allié lui dit nouveau chef de file et
donc nouveau projet celui qui sera
défendue pour les législatives est en
cours d'élaboration
eric woerth déjà chargé du programme
fillon pour la présidentielle va revoir
sa copie je pense qu'on doit plus
insister sur le pouvoir d'achat sur les
catégories moyennes sur la
désindustrialisation du pays sur l'oubli
ou l'abandon de la ruralité
sur tous ces sujets qui ont focalisé
beaucoup de la campagne et pas
suffisamment du débat le programme
définitif des républicains pour les
législatives sera présenté mardi
prochain
bureau politique voilà pour ce reportage
signé c'est stéphanie des pierres et
françois goulard
bonjour céline martel bonjour sur notre
plateau on vous retrouve vous suivez la
droite
alors dites nous un peu où on en est
plus de cacophonie maintenant c'est
l'unité derrière françois baroin
vraiment en tout cas c'est le message
qu'il souhaite faire passer donc cette
semaine on l'a vu la grande nouvelle
c'est la nomination de françois baroin
ça faisait longtemps qu'on entendait par
les assauts de son nom il était poussé à
part les sarkozystes et finalement c'est
c'est lui qui a fait l'unanimité autour
de lui une équipe de campagne
alors ce qui est assez intéressant c'est
qu'il ya plus de 40 personnes qui sont
dans son dans cette équipe
le but ça a vraiment été de rassembler
toutes les tendances du parti pour ne
froisser personne
eh bien c'est raté puisque les juppéiste
à la sortie de cette réunion se
plaignaient de ne pas être assez
représentés dans cette équipe de
campagne
une équipe de campagne qui s'est déjà
réunie pour s'organiser savoir où ils se
rendront pour soutenir quel candidat
voilà c'est un peu le plan de bataille
qui ce mec qui se met en place et et
dernier point c'est le projet qui sera
présenté mardi prochain
qu'est-ce qu'on peut y trouver dans ce
projet alors parce que on a l'impression
que tout ce qu'a fait françois fillon a
été mis de côté balayé bah en fait le le
but de tirer les leçons justement de
cette présidentielle
et on voit que françois fillon a fait de
très mauvais scores auprès des ouvriers
des des professions intermédiaires et
donc là le but c'est vraiment de
s'adresser à nouveau à ces classes
populaires et alors pour ça le projet
contient plusieurs mesures
enfin devrait contenir la plusieurs
mesures ce qu'on appelait encore le
projet définitif notamment la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires 1 c'est le retour de
travailler plus pour gagner plus avait
clamé par les sarkozystes notamment
voilà exactement ça fait plutôt
l'unanimité au sein du parti
il ya aussi la baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu 1 alors que françois fillon lui
il voulait un choc fiscal en faveur des
entreprises donc là on a un changement
de stratégie
fini aussi la suppression plutôt
l'augmentation de la tva que voulait
françois fillon ça c'est les
fonctionnaires alors les fonctionnaires
parce que c'était quand même le point
d'achoppement dans le programme de
françois fillon oliviero qu on parlera
bien sûr juste après oui en fait c'est
pas encore tranché un certain voudrait à
garder cet objectif des cinq cent mille
suppressions de postes de fonctionnaires
mais il est allé dans le temps et pour
d'autres il faut revenir à une
baisse plus raisonnable comme souhaité
par exemple alain juppé est-ce que toute
cette réorganisation si je puis dire
olivier rouquan suffit à a gardé le
parti uni jusqu'au jusqu'aux
législatives
le résultat de marine le pen dimanche va
beaucoup compter parce que le front
national peut enfoncer un coin dans la
dent lors la réorganisation accélérés
des républicains pour les législatives
mais en faveur de ce parti là comme tous
les résultats accumulés pendant le
quinquennat lors des scrutins
intermédiaires ont été de bons résultats
donc là il ya une logique
institutionnelle qui fait que pour une
logique collective et non plus personnel
que si vous voulez suscitent les
législatives on va pouvoir plutôt trouvé
un parti éventuellement qui en effet son
rap ans et les peler et avoir une
certaine efficacité électorale dans
l'explosion de la droite qui encore une
espèce d'unités en vue des élections
législatives
c'est une mais à prêter mais le score de
marine le pen va beaucoup compter quand
même parce que si elle fait un score
très important
la dynamique que veut mettre en marche
les républicains pour récupérer les
classes populaires sera de portée
relative on va dire à la céline est
certain le parti veut rester unis mais
il ya quand même certains qui ne disent
pas forcément non à emmanuel macron donc
c'est compliqué le parti est un peu
entre deux feux mais oui il ya un vrai
clivage en fait entre ceux qui affichent
clairement leur volonté de gagner ces
législatives qui compte imposer une
cohabitation à emmanuel macron et ce en
off qui sont beaucoup plus réservés sur
la possibilité de gagner il ya vraiment
des gens qui voient emmanuel macron
comme celui qui a dynamité le monde
politique actuel et il pense maintenant
comment travailler avec lui c'est le cas
des jus pays c'était le mérite des gens
comme xavier bertrand valérie pécresse
nathalie kosciusko morizet et emmanuel
macron il va tout faire pour essayer de
les récupérer
est ce qu'on peut imaginer justement
qu'il ya une fragmentation de cette
droite entre ceux qui veulent peut-être
gouverner demain avec le prochain
président de la république
et puis les autres qui veulent refonder
finalement droite ce qui est intéressant
finalement c'est que lorsque les
institutions les coutumes les traditions
vole en éclats ce sont les acteurs qui
ont la main
là j'allais dire que donc les noms vous
avez cité moins déterminant c'est à dire
que les acteurs et leurs stratégies vont
être à la base de la recomposition du
paysage
donc s'ils font le choix en effet faut
se rappeler aussi qu'il voulait gagner
un certain nombre de leaders de droite
était vraiment dans la dans l'idée
qu'ils allaient récupérer le pouvoir
donc ceci ferait jeu presque inscrit oui
il veut c'est une habitude de la saga
république s'était fait donc certains
d'entre eux vont aussi rebonds au point
où nous en sommes
laissons tomber le passé et
engageons-nous dans l' aventure qui se
présentait et qui est ouverte justement
c'est la base de choix qu'a fait
emmanuel maroc qui auraient raison même
si c'est difficile d'aller chercher la
vérité chez chacun mais qui a plus qui
voit l'avenir aujourd'hui ceux qui
veulent travailler avec emmanuel macron
ou ceux qui veulent rester dans cette
droite de pure durer parce que dans
l'opposition de demain là je pense que
plusieurs facteurs vont compter pour
répondre à votre question
l'actrice alors invoqué par exemple oui
la droite est susceptible là les
républicains sont susceptibles de ceux
de ceux en effet d'avoir de connaître
une petite scission voir une grande et
je pense que le facteur de la
composition du gouvernement va beaucoup
compter le premier gouvernement avant
législatives et ensuite le déroulement
de cette campagne électorale c'est à
dire que si les républicains sont
capables d'engager une petite dynamique
la scission sera contenue si on voit que
cette campagne ne tourne pas ça sera la
porte ouverte à une évolution majeure
ces lignes sur ce point qu'est ce qu'on
dit notamment à droite vision ou pas
tout à fait la première date à regarder
c'est le 15 mai un ace que emmanuel
macron va tenter à des débauchages
individuels
là ça pourrait être le début d'une
hémorragie ça dépend quel nom il arriva
à décrocher et puis il ya aussi une
surprise qui pourrait arriver si
emmanuel macron décide de créer un
nouveau parti comme ça ce murmure un
parti pour attirer à la fois des
socialistes et républicains dans une
sorte de grandes fédérations où
vivraient pour
temps beaucoup voilà et emmanuel macron
leur promet une investiture majorité
présidentielle qui pourrait attirer
certains jeux totalement les roulés
réponse évidemment à partir de dimanche
soir aussi merci beaucoup olivier
rouquan d'avoir été avec nous sur ce
plateau céline martèle également on vous
souhaite une très bonne suite de
programmes établis pas d'aller voter
ces deux provinces
[Musique]